m
ce vendredi 9 octobre a vu
l'inauguration du complexe du moufia
un établissement qui accompagne les
personnes en situation de handicap
lire sam institut régional des sourds et
des aveugles de marseille a inauguré son
nouvel institut en présence de son
directeur général du conseil
départemental de la rs et de l'état
le complexe du moufia propose ainsi
quatre établissements pouvant accueillir
plus de 70 adultes âgés entre 20 et 60
ans en situation de handicap sur ce site
sont réunis quatre établissements un sam
simple pour les déficients visuels donc
un service aide à la personne
1 une case dv qui est aussi pour les
déficients visuels mais c'est plus une
aide à trouver du travail pour des
personnes avec déficience visuelle et
ensuite les deux établissements dont je
m'occupe c'est-à-dire un foyer d'accueil
occupationnel et un foyer d'accueil
médicalisé
ce projet a pu voir le jour grâce à des
financements du département qui mène une
action solidaire et dynamique en faveur
des personnes porteuses de handicap
donc l'objectif en fait de créer ce même
site on retrouve trois structures c'est
qu'antérieurement nous avions trois
structures et 3 offre donc médico social
et d'accompagnement éclaté sur trois
sites à la fois sur saint françois sur
sainte marie et au bas de la rivière de
saint denis
donc l'objectif était bien donc de
répondre à un besoin de places
supplémentaires sur le territoire mais
également d'offrir aux usagers un
endroit unique un seul site où chaque
usager peut retrouver le besoin qui
correspond l'offre qui correspond à son
besoin
concernant le foyer des docus passionnel
c'est une compétence exclusive du
département
donc sur le femmes et sur le samsah
c'est une compétence partagée puisque le
femmes et le samsah il y à une partie
soins donc une partie sanitaire qui est
prise en charge par l'état
aujourd'hui le complexe du moufia
accueille dans des conditions optimales
les personnes porteuses de handicap
le centre de vie regroupe les fonctions
d'hébergement d'activités variées
adaptées aux résidents des locaux de
soins et de restauration ainsi que des
salles de bien-être je suis très content
parce que les à sa main pour beaucoup de
ce sens et je suis très très très
content parce que sans ces centaines
aujourd'hui n'arrivais pas à me déplacer
hamas et à sentir comme ils se sentent
là aujourd'hui que ce que fait déplacer
je peux sortir
c'est comme lorsque ma famille je suis
très content ici ça m'a apporté beaucoup
de choses bon aussi à tous niveaux au
niveau famille même pas moi mais moi
même ce qui a abrité offert ni sur moi
même grâce au sam sam est qu en ce sens
à 6 g arriver là pas seulement moi mais
tout avec les déformant les formateurs
et formatrices tout ça est sorti
deux groupes à des rencontres
soit à la médiathèque soit des activités
culturelles
ça nous permet de 2
d'échanger avec le
amis c'est grâce à la bonne
collaboration de l'équipe
ça nous permet d'avancer dans la vie
d'avoir une meilleure autonomie
l'important c'est très important
un hommage a été fait à martiel marianne
des cités en 2014
cette femme de coeur et d'action fut
l'interlocutrice privilégiée de l'islam
au sein du département de la genèse à
l'aboutissement du projet de création du
complexe du moufia